i think there are many reasons why
people notice certain things better than
other people particularly when it comes
to pronunciation but i'm sure the same
is true in terms of noticing things in
grammar hi there steve coffman here
today i want to talk about noticing in
language learning
there's a thing called the noticing
hypothesis which just created some
controversy in
in linguistic circles but i'm going to
talk about how noticing influences our
ability to learn languages remember if
you enjoy these videos please subscribe
you can click on the bell for
notifications
so
i have said before that one of the best
descriptions of language learning of
what is involved in learning a language
is something i heard at a conference of
language teachers in san diego where
one of the people presenting there said
language learning consists of three
things the attitude of the learner
the time spent with the language not
listening to explanations in english or
something
so time spent with the language attitude
time spent with the language and the
ability to notice
now i notice that i notice things
when i'm learning a language and i
notice them at different times
now apparently there is a thing called
the noticing hypothesis which was
proposed in 1960 by a professor
and again as with so much in the sort of
academic approach to language learning
he sort of
as i can understand it trying to read
the explanations online of noticing
hypothesis he sort of presents a
somewhat extreme case of the importance
of noticing to language acquisition and
therefore it became sort of
in opposition to or in some ways in
contradiction to what krashen said about
the importance of input sort of just
naturally absorbing the language you
know he implies that you have to
kind of deliberately notice things in
order
to be able to acquire them
and uh so i you know i invite you to
google for it uh wikipedia or elsewhere
and see if you can make sense of this
linguistics debate i can't really but i
would like to talk about noticing
my impression of the importance of
noticing to language learning
first of all
when we begin with a new language
we don't notice much
it's all noise to us like if you're
trying to notice the pronunciation
you can't really hear it that well
and so everything is kind of like a
blank slate
but certain things start to fall into
place
naturally
and as we and so that we start to notice
certain things we notice
that uh you know how certain things are
pronounced and some people may notice
better than others
but as
we notice more
than other things that had previously
been hidden
come forward and we start to notice
them
a bit like a jigsaw muscle when you
start a jigsaw puzzle it's totally blank
as you start to put some of the pieces
of the jigsaw puzzle
into place you start to see
you know greater likelihood of where
some of the pieces might fit
and and language learning is very much
like that so you start to notice that
there's a gap here that maybe this is
where this piece belongs
and uh certainly that's been my
experience
uh
you know in russian for example
um you know any un um
accentuated syllable that has the letter
o what we would call the sound o in it
becomes a you don't notice that at first
you know and then eventually you start
to notice that and once you've noticed
that now you're ready to notice
something else
and i don't know that there's any
special order for these things except to
say that
the more things we have already noticed
the more
new things we can start to notice now
is it a deliberate activity that of
noticing okay i think first of all the
more we listen and read
the more we naturally
almost
subconsciously notice things because
we're naturally this is sort of
krashen's input hypothesis we're just
gradually acquiring the language our
brain is starting to
recognize certain patterns in the
language so that even without
deliberately trying to notice anything
we start to notice things all right
and but i have
had the experience as i listened to a
mini story for the 30th time i noticed
something that i hadn't noticed before
so we are continuing to notice just
through this process of
listening and reading
however
and some people notice better than
others uh if if someone pronounces
something in a foreign language i will
tend to notice that pronunciation to
pick up up on it right away and i've
said you know i
when i was in japan and i'd have
visitors from north america who would be
introduced to mr sato
some people would say mr sato
because it's written s-a-t-o so they see
the name card s-a-t-o that should be
saito
even though they hear him pronounce his
own name as sato
so they don't notice the pronunciation
other people will immediately hear sato
and go subtle so
the ability to notice varies with people
now are there
psychological reasons why some people
notice better than others some people
are more willing to just go with what
they hear whereas other people are more
stuck with the way the word is written
we have all kinds of examples of people
who
you know my father who was from
czechoslovakia
word was ward w-o-r-d because to him
that's the way it should be pronounced
that's how it's written so there's a
certain resistance to the fact that in
english actually it's pronounced word is
not pronounced ward
so i think there are many reasons why
people notice certain things better than
other people particularly when it comes
to pronunciation but i'm sure the same
is true in terms of noticing things in
grammar now what can help us notice
first of all we have to want to notice
and second of all obviously
a teacher or a grammatical explanation
can help us notice like i have very
often read
an explanation of something
and then i start to notice it when i
next see that in a text whether it be a
structure or even some aspect of
pronunciation
however we have to be ready we have to
be ready to receive that bit of
information because if it comes too
early
we don't know enough
about the language we haven't
experienced enough about the language
for that
hint
to be useful
so maybe having struggled with russian
for a certain amount of time and
say i'm able to pronounce certain things
at that point if someone points out that
actually the unaccentuated
uh
uh you know syllables with o are
pronounced
now i notice it if that had been told to
me right up front at the beginning i i
don't think i would have been able to
retain that
and i think i would have missed it the
next time and the next time and the next
time that it showed up so there is a
question of of timing insofar as
noticing is concerned timing both in
terms of what you're going to naturally
notice and also in terms of
what you know teachers or grammar
resources or other explanations can how
in terms of how useful they can be in
helping you to notice but i do feel that
in order to and i guess this is where i
agree with aspects of the
uh noticing hypothesis
uh you have to be able to notice things
first before you can
actually start to use them yourself
and and we've all had the experience
that once we noticed something that for
the longest time we never noticed once
we noticed it here all of a sudden you
start to see it there we see it there
and we see it there and there is a term
for that which i've forgotten but
once certain things are either pointed
out to us or we become aware of them we
start to notice them then we see them
elsewhere and i think noticing is very
much a part of your brain
starting to you know recognize patterns
in the language so that
initially your comprehension improves
and eventually your ability to pronounce
things correctly or to you know use the
structure correctly will improve so
noticing is very much a part of the
process i think the biggest
contributor to our ability to notice is
the quantity of content that we consume
reading and listening
another important factor is our
willingness to notice our willingness to
accept this that in other words we we
leave aside the prejudices from our own
language that the structure should be
this way because this is the way we say
it in our language or
this should be pronounced this way
because that's how it's pronounced in
our language or that's how those are the
values that those letters have in our
native language so you know more
willingness to accept and and also the
desire to want to hear what's going on
so there is an element of wanting to
notice and then there's also the sort of
external factors that can help us notice
such as a teacher such as somebody
pointing something out pointing out a
mistake for example
these are all part and parcel of what
helps us to notice and i think we have
to be able to notice in order to improve
in a language so i strayed a bit from
the sort of pure
noticing hypothesis but
those are the ways i have noticed that
noticing helps me learn languages so
thank you for listening bye for now